The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: My name
is Mark Harvey,
and I am teaching a
course this semester
on musical improvisation.
We have our students
here this evening,
and [INAUDIBLE] the
rest of you [INAUDIBLE].
And in conjunction
with the course,
we're running this
concert series,
which is the last of
four concerts we've had.
And you see on the
page that you picked up
at the door, another very
different kinds of programs
that we've had.
And we're thrilled to include
in this particular [INAUDIBLE]
we call Tre Corda with
Tim Ray over here,
Greg Hopkins, and
Eugene Friesen.
So please welcome them.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA, "SHADOW
PLAY"]
[APPLAUSE]
TIM RAY: Thank you.
Thanks very much.
And thank you all
for coming out.
It's great to see a great
audience here at MIT.
We are Tre Corda and
very glad to be here and.
And as Mark mentioned,
the gentlemen
up here on stage-- on stage?
Do we call this a stage?
It's where we're playing,
so I guess it's a stage.
Anyway, I just
want to remind you
that is on trumpet and
flugelhorn Greg Hopkins.
[APPLAUSE]
And on cello, Eugene Friesen.
So that first piece you heard
was a composition of Eugene
Friesen's called
"Shadow Play," which
of course is an
amazing pizzicato
technique on the cello.
And we love to jump in on some
of Eugene's pizzicato creations
as we did on that song.
We're celebrating a new CD.
We have a new CD, the three
of us, called Squeaky Toy.
And we're going to
play-- "Shadow Play,"
the song we just played
is on the new CD.
And we're going to play some
other ones on the new CD
as well.
And continuing on with
another song from that disk.
This is the first movement of
the sonata for trumpet, cello,
and piano composed
by Greg Hopkins.
And the title of this
movement is "Sneakers."
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA, "SNEAKERS"]
[APPLAUSE]
GREG HOPKINS: Thank
you very much.
Yeah, it's such a joy to have
these wonderful musicians play
the music you're
hearing in your head.
And it comes out like that.
Thank you so much, guys.
This next one I also wrote.
And it's an homage
to my late cat.
His name was Cargassian.
And he was very deft at walking
in the dark up on the mantels.
And you could hear the china
just clinking together.
Nothing ever fell or broke.
But it just tingled
a little bit.
So you knew he was there.
Anyway, so please
enjoy "Cargassian."
He had blue hair.
Nothing to do with
the [INAUDIBLE].
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA,
"CARGASSIAN"]
[APPLAUSE]
TIM RAY: Eugene and
I had the opportunity
to work with some of the
students in Mark Harvey's
improvisation class today.
And that's their assignment.
They have to play
that for us next week.
[LAUGHTER]
So [INAUDIBLE].
GREG HOPKINS: Get stratching.
TIM RAY: Get scratching.
So we're going to continue on.
This is a recent piece that
I wrote, pretty recent.
GREG HOPKINS: Tim, this is the
first time we're playing it.
TIM RAY: So I guess--
[LAUGHTER]
I guess that makes it recent.
No, this was for the
occasion of my wife
and I, who's here tonight, for
our 25th wedding anniversary,
one of the things we
did to mark that was we
bought this clock,
this big chiming clock.
And there's a long story
that goes behind it.
But basically the ones
that were really cool
that sound beautiful and
that look really nice,
we couldn't afford those.
[LAUGHTER]
So we got this kind of sort
of smallish and the case
is a little misshapen.
And it's only got one hand.
And it makes this
horrendous chiming sound.
It's really bad.
Like for the first month
after we got the clock,
every hour the
dogs would run out
of the room,
because they thought
something terrible
was about to happen.
But now the dogs are used to it.
And we're used to it.
We actually kind of fell in
love with this clock now.
Another thing I did for
this was I wrote a song.
And the title of
this song is Joy.
And if you listen
at the end, you
will here 25 chimes
for the 25 years.
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA, "JOY"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA]
TIM RAY: Thank you, thank you.
That of course, from the opera
Carmen, or our version of that.
That's also kind of neat for us.
Actually, Mark, I think
summed it up perfectly
before the show.
He said, yeah, that manages to
offend the French, the Spanish,
and the Cubans all at once.
I think he's right, too, not
to mention classical music
in general.
So we're going to give
Eugene a breather.
And Greg and I are
going to do a duet.
And I don't know what
we're going to play,
because I never know
what we're going to play.
We'll find out
when we get there.
[INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA, "LITTLE
ROOTIE TOOTIE"]
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
What song was that?
First of all-- OK,
title, anybody?
Title?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was going
to say, composer.
Thelonious Monk, very good.
Thank you, Alan.
"Little Rootie Tootie,"
is the name of that.
Written for his
son, apparently he
called his son
Little Rootie Tootie.
EUGENE FRIESEN: And now for
something completely different.
TIM RAY: And now--
Can you set this up?
You can find the music.
EUGENE FRIESEN: OK, sure thing.
This shows a little of the
different side of improvising.
This is a piece that was
originally a [INAUDIBLE].
As we were discussing
this afternoon, some of us
benefit from launching
into an improvisation
by kind of limiting
the boundaries
of the language a little bit.
In this case, this
was pretty much
a diotronic piece that
was a free improve.
It was recorded in a beautiful
cathedral, St. John the Divine,
in one November night in 1986.
And thank goodness
the tape was rolling.
It turned out to
be something that I
wanted to play again and again.
I call it "First Ride."
And we went back and
transcribed the original improvs
so we could perform it again.
Tim did an amazing
job of reinventing
the improvised piano part.
I'm pretty much
playing the cello part
that was improvised that
night some years ago.
This is called "First Ride."
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA, "FIRST
RIDE"]
[APPLAUSE]
TIM RAY: Thank have.
Thanks very much.
We've got a couple more left.
Now I'm trying to decide.
As you can see, we
have way too much
music for the time we have left.
So we're going to pick and
choose a little bit here.
You guys want to do Bartok?
Let's do Bartok.
As I'm sure you've probably
figured out by now,
we're playing a lot
with classical music.
And we're obviously
influenced by classical music.
It's a lot of what we're doing.
And now we're
actually going to try
to play some classical music.
I know.
I know, I thought
the same thing.
And these guys-- well, anyway.
But of course, we're not
going to play it straight.
This is something else, and by
the way, it's on the new CD.
I was introduced to these piano
pieces, Bartok, Bela Bartok,
piano pieces back
when I was at college.
And I was immediately
attracted to them
because the title of
them is "Improvisations."
Then I thought, cool.
I get to just make up stuff
and call it classical music.
But it turns out, it
doesn't work that way.
You have to play the
notes that are out there.
But they're called
improvisations,
but they're all written out.
So I was a little disappointed.
But nevertheless, I loved these.
I play these pieces,
and I love them.
And I kind of rediscovered them
by accident a few years ago.
And I thought this would be
great to, first of all, to try
with the trio,
and second of all,
to actually put
some improvisation
into the "Improvisations."
So with apologies
to Bela Bartok.
We're going to do three-- these
are eight short piano pieces.
And we're going to do three
of them, number five, number
three, and number eight.
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA,
"IMPROVISATIONS"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks very much.
Thank you.
So we're going to
do one more song
and get our in the beautiful
cool air once again.
But before we do, a
couple of reminders.
If you're interested
in a CD, we've
got the new CD, the new
Tre Corda CD, Squeaky Toy.
And I'm told that my merchandise
staff out there gives
huge discounts to students.
Huge discounts for students.
And Greg Hopkins's new CD is
also out on the table, right?
Greg Hopkins has a new
sextet, a quintet plus one,
as he calls it, which to
me sounds like a sextet,
but apparently it's different.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG HOPKINS:
You're the plus one.
TIM RAY: I'm the plus one?
OK.
So look for that as well.
We also have, for
the new CD, you know,
we're all old guys,
relatively speaking.
I'm very proud of myself.
I actually have download cards
out there, for a discount rate.
I forget what the
discount rate is.
She'll tell you.
You can buy a little
download card.
It's cheaper than a CD.
That much I know.
And go download
it from a CD Baby.
So that's a cool thing
to do if you just
want the digital,
the ones and zeroes.
That's a good way to do that.
And mailing list, if you
want to get on email list.
You can also do
that at the table.
And I think that's it
except for two more things.
Of course I want to
give a big thank you
to MIT and to the folks
here at Killian Hall
for providing this
beautiful space for us
to play in, and particularly
to my good friend
Mark Harvey who invited us here.
[APPLAUSE]
As I said before, we're
really glad to be finishing up
the series of improvising
groups here at MIT.
And we're having a great time.
And again, if you
want to come find us,
go sign up on our email list.
And lastly, but not
leastly, please help me
thank once again on
cello, Eugene Friesen.
[APPLAUSE]
And on trumpet, Greg Hopkins.
GREG HOPKINS: And our fearless
leader, Tim Ray on piano.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM RAY: So I'm looking at
three or four songs here.
Should we-- do you have an idea?
Oh, you're pointing at Greg.
We could do "Theme Park" or
we could "Church Rhythm."
Let's do "Church Rhythm."
OK, we're going to do another--
we started with a Eugene
Friesen composition.
We're going to end with a
Eugene Friesen composition.
This is entitled,
"Church Rhythm."
[MUSIC - TRE CORDA, "CHURCH
RHYTHM"]
[APPLAUSE]